I I made John promise that he wouldn't
salt me in his introduction and and I
think he failed except he called me a
theoretical physicist so I think by by
his standards did that he succeeded
so thank you for that introduction and
it's great to be here I wanted to start
off my talk by acknowledging my
co-conspirators in this effort first and
foremost is Martine casado who's a
graduate from here in 2007 should be
familiar to all of you I believe he's a
consulting professor actually here and
he is really the inventor of Software
Defined Networking he remained the
intellectual leader in that field some
six or seven years later and everything
I'll be saying today is really largely
due to him then there's another
character you're familiar with who when
he's not starring in James Bond videos
actually has been leading the Software
Defined Networking effort as well and
then there's somebody you probably don't
know very well which is tamuka ponen who
has played a major role in architecting
Software Defined Networking and in his
spare time is best internet architect in
the world period by a large margin so I
wanted to spend a little time talking
about my co-conspirators rather than
just putting up their names on the first
slide because when I was at Xerox PARC
about 20 years ago they did survey
asking how do you choose what problems
you work on and most people said you
know intellectual depth or practical
relevance or you know potential
commercial applications and I said I
choose who I work with and then I choose
what I work on and because for me the
idea of co-creating with people that I
like and respect is the highest pleasure
in research and so for the work in
Software Defined Networking I've had the
best of both worlds both intellectually
interesting work and working with people
that I have the utmost affection and awe
of now of course in Software Defined
Networking lots of other people have
done very important work there's a huge
group at Stanford that's done it the
open networking lab that that was formed
by guru and that's led by gurus that
have formed out of the Berkeley and
Stanford groups then there are people at
many other universities and many other
commercial endeavors whose butt
working on this and their ideas
obviously will be reflected in my talk
but I want to you know most of it flows
from these co-conspirators I want to
start my talk with a couple of
clarifications first I want to
acknowledge that coming to Stanford to
give a talk about software-defined
networking is a huge exercise and
bringing coal to Newcastle and at first
I turned down the invitation because I
thought this is stupid and then I
realized that NIC and guru probably have
never given a departmental wide talk and
software-defined networking at Stanford
and I've never given a department-wide
talking on Sdn at Berkeley but guru has
and so maybe the right aphorism here is
that nobody can be a prophet in their
homeland and so you have to go to some
other university to be able to
articulate your vision of what Software
Defined Networking is second is this
talk has no technical depth zero that
you're not going to find any interesting
algorithms there's not going to be any
new results if we used to not be able to
do this and now we can do that and
that's because Sdn really is not a
technological development in the
classical sense Sdn is nothing more than
a way of arranging functionality
arranging network functionality now you
might think that that's an insult but
the internet architecture is nothing
more than how you arrange network
functionality and that turned out pretty
well so the point is there is nothing
clever about the internet architecture
there's no place where you can look and
say wow they solved a really hard
technical problem there it's all about
wisdom about getting the right solution
not being clever so this is going to be
an architectural talk an unabashedly
architectural talk but academia academia
in architecture don't always mix oh well
there's a user interface expert who
played a long role at Apple I believe
he's at Northwestern now who says
academics don't get paid I mean get paid
for being clever not for being right so
in this talk though I am NOT going to
try and prove to you that I am clever
because I'm not I'm going to try and
argue that we're right because we are ok
so the talk will have three main
components I'm going to give a basic
introduction to Sdn I know a lot of you
already know a lot about it but if you
don't understand the basics the rest of
the talk is a waste of time this is a
departmental wide talk so I want to make
sure we're all on the same page and my
twist on Sdn is probably a little
different than what you're used to then
I'm going to talk a little bit about
what we thought when Sdn was invented
what were the the ideas we had in our
mind and then what we think now and
after five years and then I'm going to
explore the opportunities and
implications of these changes in
thinking and what it means for the
future of networking so I'll start with
talking about the basic introduction to
Sdn and there I want us to talk about
its roots because its roots are deep and
broad it didn't just come out of one
isolated piece of work there have been
people who are doing early efforts to
try and separate the control plate from
the data plane I'll explain what those
are later but epsilon people at
Cambridge long time ago there were
commercial efforts to manage wireless
networks certainly aruba later Meraki
have been using centralized methods that
look a lot like SDM there were effort
internal efforts to tame data center
networks at Google and Amazon and
elsewhere that looked a lot like Sdn and
certainly where I got involved with the
Stanford group was in these academic
projects to revamp network management
but there were other projects at CMU the
4t project ADT research the RCP project
there are all these people who are
working not exactly in Sdn but in
closely related areas Sdn most people
think that it originated when the NOx
network operating system in the OpenFlow
specification came out in 2008 and
that's sort of when it officially
started but what I wanted to make clear
is it came out of a much longer
intellectual history of people working
on related things and when you have this
broader intellectual movement of people
focusing on similar questions it's
driven by some need and so the question
is what was the thing that was driving
all of us to think about these problems
and they are first of all that networks
are hard
manage sort of initially put this in
past temps on the slides the networks
were hard to manage but they're still
hard to manage
so networks are very hard to manage it
takes sort of an order of magnitude more
assisted men help to administer a single
switch that it does to administer a
single computational node so that
they're compared to other things we have
in computer science networks are hard to
manage they're very hard to evolve that
is if you want to introduce function new
functionality into the network it's much
harder in networks than it is and other
software systems were used to and
network design is not driven by formal
principles and the easy way to look at
that if you look at an operating systems
course or a distributed systems course
or a database course they're oriented
around some fundamental principles of
synchronization and mutual exclusion and
so forth that you build off of that
helps people organize the way they think
about the field the way we and that
means it of all of us who teach
networking it's basically a big bag of
protocols we have no principles we just
teach them a various set of protocols so
those are symptoms of why we started
looking but what's the root cause why do
we have these problems in networking and
the way to think about that is to go and
ask well how do we build the systems
that work well what do we do what makes
it work there and what we do there is we
bake break the problem into tractable
pieces and this is most pithily
expressed by Barbara Liskov and her
Turing Award lecture where she said
modularity based on abstraction is the
way things get done that is that's the
one trick we have if you want to build a
system that scales and works use
modularity based on abstraction so if
you're looking for root causes the
answer is simple which is if you can't
manage if you can't evolve and you can't
understand the system then chances are
you don't have the abstractions right
so if that's true that what abstractions
do we need for networks now to answer
that we'd have to realize that networks
have two different planes or two
different problem very different
problems being solved in networks one is
what we call the data plane which is a
packet arrives at a switch or a router
and I will use switch and router
completely interchangeably has a packet
header the switch a router looks at the
packet header it looks at some
forwarding state that's sitting there
and figured out what do I do with that
packet do I drop it do I send it out
port 17 do I send it out port 27 what do
I do with that packet that's the data
plane this happens on nanosecond
timescales and it's completely local
then there's the control plane the
control plane is how that forwarding
State got there if you get there through
distributed algorithms if you get there
through manual configuration it's not
slower timescales it's tens of
milliseconds two days if it's manual
configuration and it's inherently
non-local that is the information has to
come from the outside world a router by
itself can't figure out where it should
send a packet so these are two very
different problems one is local and very
fast one is non-local and not very fast
they're very different problems they
probably have different abstractions
or the data plane we have a very
well-known set of abstractions that's
layering that if you go and write a
network application you don't write a
piece of spaghetti code that goes all
the way from the application down to low
level networking code you write your
application on reliable transport you
write reliable transfer it on
best-effort global packet delivery you
write that on best-effort local packet
delivery and you write that on local
physical transfer of bits now this
layering is why the internet was so
successful because you broke the problem
into tractable pieces when you wanted to
solve a networking problem you didn't
have to solve everything at once
and it enabled innovation at every layer
independently that is if you had some
new let's say optical technology that
you wanted to use in the network you
just put it in that's a new way to do
local transfer of bits everything else
in the stack and remain exactly the same
you didn't have to rewrite the entire
networking stack you just do a local
change and everything works and this has
allowed the internet to survive many
orders of magnitude change in the speed
and the scale and diversity of uses you
know six or seven orders of magnitude
that's a pretty amazing feat to have the
same architecture still work with almost
no change so that's the data plane and
and we got those abstractions right we
not including me but but we as the
community got those abstractions right
what about the control plane well today
the control plane has no abstractions
there are a wide variety of mechanisms
trying to do a wide variety of things
you want to do routing that is getting
packets from here to there you want to
do various kinds of isolation to make
sure the packets from here don't get to
here and you want to do various kinds of
traffic engineering trying to spread the
load out across the network so you don't
have overloaded links for each one of
those tasks we have a set of mechanisms
and the problem is that there's no
modularity if you want to write a new
out router the algorithm you start from
scratch
there aren't these well-known building
blocks that you can start with you start
from scratch and because you are always
starting from scratch you actually have
limited
functionality that is rotting algorithms
aren't very good our isolation
mechanisms aren't very good and our
traffic engineering mechanisms are
actually pitiful so this is a classic
case of the masses because we built
mechanism without abstraction so if you
want to know why was Sdn developed it
was because we were struggling with a
control plane that was built without any
abstraction and it was a embarrassing
mess so what should we so if that's the
diagnosis what's the cure what are the
abstractions we should be using so
finding good abstractions is all about
finding what pieces of functionality you
want to reuse okay so let's think about
what you would be doing when you want to
design a control plane you know to
accomplish some task what are the
components that you would need to do
first you need to figure out what the
network looks like if you're going to do
something like routing I need to know
what the network looks like before I can
decide how I can possibly route so step
one I figure out what the network looks
like then I figure out how to route on
that network or if I'm doing isolation I
figure out how to not route to make sure
that packet don't get from here to there
and then once I figured that out I
figure out how do I tell the switches
what to do meaning how do I install the
forwarding State in them so they do the
right thing okay so I start by figuring
out what the network looks like I then
figure out how to accomplish my goal and
then I've tell the switches to do what I
want now which one's of those are
reusable which ones are these are
reusable so clearly figuring out what
the network looks like you're going to
use that for a wide variety of control
tasks so that's reusable figuring out
how to do that task on a particular
network topology that's very specific to
the task
that's not reusable but then telling the
switches once you've figured out what to
do that's reusable so those are the two
things we're going to reuse you now in
exactly 14 minutes know everything you
need to know about Sdn that is SDA
it is the use of those to control plain
abstractions that's all it is so I told
you there was no cleverness so you have
the global network view that provides
information about the network the way
that's typically implemented is with
something we call a network operating
system that's just software running on
servers that happen to be placed in the
network the forwarding model is the
standard way of telling a switch how to
forward if you've heard of open flow
that's what the role open flow plays
it's basically just the way you can tell
us which if the packet header looks like
this then take this action just a just a
standard way of telling it that simple
statement so given those abstractions
then Sdn is nothing more than layers for
the control plane just like we had
layers for the data plane that's layers
for the control plane we start with a
bunch of switches connected by some
wires we then build the network
operating system remember this is just
software running on servers but these
servers talk to all the switches they do
so using this forwarding model open flow
like
they use the information they get from
the switches to build this global
network view that is they know the
topology and then you build a control
program on top of that topology and that
control program can be routing it can be
access control it can be whatever you
want and I call this layers because you
have a very clean separation of concerns
the control program has no other job
than to express the operators goals like
if they want to do connectivity or if
they want to do isolation that's what
the control program is concerned with
its implemented on top of this global
network view the control program doesn't
care where that view came from it
doesn't care how you found it out it
just said you give me the view I'll
figure out what I'm supposed to do and
I'll compute this forwarding state that
every switch should have the network
operating system sits there and it says
I will talk to the switches and I will
compute the global network view all
gather that information and that when
the control plane I mean the control
program tells me I will convey the
configurations down to the switches I
don't understand what the control
program is trying to do I don't need to
I'll just tell the switches and the
switches just follow orders from the
network operating system the very clean
separation of concerns and so now you
can have independent innovation at every
layer you can build better routers and
switches and as long as they support
this interface they're fine you can
build better network operating systems
as long as they take orders from the
control program they're fine and you can
change what your control program does
and the other layers can remain intact
so while this is very simple it is a
major change in the paradigm that is the
control mechanism now is no longer a
distributed algorithm like we think of
routing algorithms it merely uses the
network operating system API it is
nothing more than a graph algorithm
giving me a graph I will figure out what
I should do if you want the shortest
path I use Dijkstra if you want K
disjoint paths you go write some
complicated graph algorithm that
computes K disjoint graphs but it's
local it is nothing to do with
distribution so that makes it much
easier to manage evolve and understand
those were the three symptoms we
identified earlier that networks were
bad at and once you go to this paradigm
they now become much easier it also ends
up with a very clean separation of
control and data plates that is the data
plane is now completely handled in the
switch but the control plane is now
running on these servers in the network
so they're completely separated whereas
today when you buy a box it has the
control plane the data plane all jumbled
together in a proprietary closed box
this separation allows you to use
commodity Hardware and third-party
software it also allows you to do much
better testing of the network because
there's this clean separation you can
test the control plane independent of
the underlying hardware there's been a
lot of work at Stanford and at Berklee
trying to take advantage of this and try
and elevate network testing and
troubleshooting to a first-class citizen
the way it is in the chip industry and
other places where they do this testing
very well so this separation makes
networking look a lot more like the rest
of the industry but everything I've said
so far is based on what we thought five
years ago so now I want to step back and
say given that it's been five years we
got a lot of it right but we had a
couple of areas where we were just flat
wrong so the rest of the talk I want to
explore what those areas were why
they're important and what the
implications are for the future of
networking
but I want to be clear that if you think
about Sdn is just sort of observing
modularity and networking that part we
got right and all of the additional
insights that we have now are about
finding new and more advanced kinds of
modularity that is our search for
modularity was right we've just
discovered additional modularity
whatever you build a system it sometimes
takes you a while to get the modularity
right and it's taken us five years and
we're probably still not right so let me
list a couple of things we used to think
we used to think that the control
program would compute the configurations
that is the forwarding state for all the
network switches we thought that
switches were relatively homogeneous and
roll and function we thought the network
was comprised entirely of Hardware
switches of course it was what other
kind of switches are there and we
thought the native network data plane
with fairly simple that's been the dogma
about the Internet is that it has a very
simple data plate so what we now think
is that those are all wrong okay
so what I want to do is go through each
one of these and explained individually
where we're wrong and why you should
care that we were wrong let's go to
misconception number one the control
program configures all of the switches
that is that it's job is to go and
compute what the forwarding state should
be in all the switches so what is the
role of a control program control
programs are how operators express their
network requirements and policies that
is should everybody be connected should
these people not be able to talk to
these people that's what the control
program is supposed to Express
the control program should not be in
charge of implementing those
requirements for a simple reason which
is one of the goals of modularity is to
push complexity into the reusable
portions of the system and keep the
things that you have to write on a per
application basis very simple and you
want control programs which are written
on sort of a per site or per application
basis you want to keep those as simple
as possible and push the complexity into
the reusable code so you don't want your
control program responsible for
implementing so let me illustrate that
with an example so here we have a
network we have host a a and host B and
then here a bunch of switches connected
by links and the operators goal is to
prevent eighth packets from reaching B
let's say this is a visitor's laptop in
the lobby of your corporation and this
is a back-end database that holds all of
your company secrets and you would like
to make sure the packets remai don't get
to be that's a natural requirement so if
you did it with a standard Sdn method
what you would say is the control
program would then instantiate
forwarding entries that says if you see
a packet from a going to be drop it and
you would have to enter those forwarding
entries at enough places in the network
so that it was impossible for a packet
ever to get from A to B and the problem
is that then the control program must
respond to through ology and routing
changes let's say I put in a new link
from here to here the control program
would have to know oh there's a path
available I better put in another
forwarding entry that blocks the
delivery of packets now it becomes hard
to write a correct control program
because it's got to monitor all changes
in topology and routing not impossible
but it's hard it's way too hard that
much harder than it should be so that's
where what we call network
virtualization comes in what we do is we
introduce a new abstraction and a new
Sdn layer the abstraction is a virtual
topology that is this is purely logical
we use switches that you can configure
so it's a logical switch that you can
put flow into
and that's how the operator can express
the requirements and policies and then
there's a layer that we call the network
hypervisor that translates those
requirements into the physical switch so
you can think of it as sort of a
compiler for virtual topologies that
says if these are your policies
I will then compile them into
configurations of low-level Hardware
low-level physical switches so if you go
back to this example this is the global
network for you the virtual topology
that the operator would use to say
here's my network it's just one big
switch and I know I have a host de
somewhere and I have a host B somewhere
and all I want to tell you is if you see
a packet from A to B drop it at that
point the control program is done it is
told the network all of the semantics
that are specific to its application
it's now network hypervisors job to
insert these flow entries and if the
network topology change it's the
hypervisors job to follow those topology
changes and make sure you have the flow
entries so now we've made it much easier
to write the control program a lot
harder to write the compiler but
compilers are always hard to write
that's okay so we take this picture and
what we do is we insert a new layer this
network hypervisor and the virtual
topology you write your control programs
on the virtual topology and that's
apology will differ depending on what
job you you have and then the network
hypervisor translates that or compiles
that virtual topology into what your
physical network looks like based on the
global view and then your network
operating system carries that down to
the actual physical switches so
virtualization is the killer app for Sdn
consider a multi-tenant datacenter
Rackspace Amazon so you have lots of
customers who want to move their network
to the cloud and black space and Amazon
want to allow their customers to specify
their policies of what VMs are allowed
to talk to what other VMs in their
virtual network so they allow them to
specify a virtual topology Vic has their
policies and requirements and then the
data centers network hypervisor takes
all of these and I mean thousands of
them and compiles them down to low-level
configuration so that everybody's
individual policies are met this is
something that you could not do with
today's technology or before Sdn sure
you could do it with a few having
thousands and having them change
dynamically you couldn't do it and so
this is what people are paying money for
this is the killer app
now there are long-term implications of
network virtualization one is that in
the long run virtualization may be more
important than Sdn itself
Sdn may be very useful it certainly is
now for implementing virtualization but
in the long run it may be virtualization
that's actually the thing that adds
value that is that's what people are
actually willing to pay for because it
makes it easier for them to manage the
network in Sdn is a means to an end
rather than an end enough itself meaning
five years from now somebody may invent
some other technology that supports
network virtualization that's better or
worse than Sdn but what will be
important I think in the long run is
that we have some kind of network
virtualization we can also extend this
to much more general abstractions the
idea of virtual topologies just beings
analogical networks that do forwarding
that happens to be the use people are
making of it right now but you can
extend this to include much higher level
functionalities like authentication and
so forth and actually allow these
virtual topologies to express sort of
application level semantics of who's
allowed to talk to who and allow the
network hypervisor to then enforce those
the network level that would make it
much easier to build these large-scale
applications so that's something that
may happen in the longer term and that
network virtualization completely
decouples the control program which
expresses the operators goals from the
physical network and what that means is
that the operators now abstractly
Express the requirements and the network
hypervisor has complete freedom and how
it implements those desires and that's
going to be important
let's go to a misconception number two
switch is a relatively homogeneous and
rollin function and all I mean by that
is if this is a network then when you
implement your functionality just so
that you know you sort of putting these
flow entries and they're spread
throughout the network and you don't
treat switches any differently than than
any other a priori so let's explore that
when you think about what happens when
you have a host sending a packet through
a network there are three different
logical interfaces first of all the host
is telling the network something which
is I want this packet delivered to this
destination and maybe something about
quality of service that's the host
talking to the network then as the
packet goes through and hits each router
the packet is telling something to the
router it's saying this is who I am you
should look at me and figure out what
are your forwarding state you want to
use to forward okay so the packet is
trying to identify itself to the router
and meanwhile while all these packets
are running around the operator network
operators try to control the network so
the operators trying to tell the network
something about traffic engineering or
isolation that's a network level concern
an operator level concern so these are
relatively independent interfaces okay
so how are they implemented in today's
networks so for current networks the
packet header itself is used for both
the host talking to the network and a
packet talking to a router or switch
that is when a packet arrives at any
switch the switch says first what was
the host trying to do ie what
destination was this going to and then
it says and now I need to use that
information to look up in my forwarding
State to figure out how to forward the
packet so it's doing both of those
interfaces with the same header but
current networks have no general
operator network interface that is the
way the operator controls the network is
a completely kludgy and not worthy of
the name interface Sdn gives you this
complete programmatic beautifully clean
way of the operator controlling the
network but it does nothing to separate
the host network in the packet router
interface
and as you still use the packet header
and you look at it at every router or
switch along the way
now MPLS is a technology the the non
networking people don't you know
probably don't know the only thing you
need to know about it a it's used widely
in in large networks and it makes a
distinction between the edge and the
core of the networks the edge uses the
header as the host network interface
that is when the packet first hits the
first hop switch the edge router looks
at and says what was the host trying to
do it then slaps on something we call a
label think of a label just as a bag of
bits it's only meaningful within the
network it means nothing to the host so
it inserts an MPLS label and then the
core the interior of the network doesn't
look at the packet header at all it just
looks at that label and says somebody
already interpreted what this host was
trying to do they put this label on it
from now on I just look at the label and
that's enough for me to know how to
forward this packet so what we should
have done five years ago is recognized
that MPLS was right and we should have
incorporated into Sdn meaning we should
have edge routers look at the full
packet header insert a label into the
packet and the course switches which I
will sometimes call a fabric um or just
based on that label they don't look at
the rest of the packet header that's
already been looked at at the edge this
now creates a very clean network
modularity the host network interface is
handled completely by the edge the
packet router interface is handled by
the label in the core and Sdn handles
the operator Network interface so once
again we find more modularity by
separating this out we have very clean
separation of concerns and we do each
job once we do it right rather than
having it all bunched together
now let me consider two controversial
claims about this edge core split one is
that the core can focus just on packet
delivery and as operators have a bunch
of requirements and the claim here is
that all of them but connectivity that
is just m2m packet delivery can be
implemented at the edge and as if I want
to block access control if I want to do
isolation I can do all of that at the
edge the core must obviously deliver
packets and I will include in terms of
packet delivery also multicast and
quality of service but other than that
the edge can do everything else now
every time I give this talk to a
networking audience somebody gets this
an oh here's this use that you can't do
at the edge and then it'll give me some
crazy scheme that of course you can't do
at the edge so I've modified it that the
edge can do everything else that people
are willing to pay for okay and that I
still stand by so this is the Sdn
equivalent of the end and print of the
end-to-end principle and networking said
you take functionality out of the
network and you put whatever possible
you put it in the Antos and this is just
saying you keep the core of the network
simple you take all the functionality
you can out of the network core and you
put it all of the complexity to the edge
very similar reasoning and I think it
will be as important at Sdn networks as
the NBN principle was for the internet
so you end up with a network that looks
like this which is you have these core
switches you have these edge switches
and the core nodes only provide
end-to-end connectivity so if I have a
packet here its job the job of these
nodes are just to get the packet from
here to there and that's it okay they
don't do anything else and the edge no
do all of the other functionality so the
long-term implications of this are first
of all we've now told the core you have
one job just get the packets edge to
edge don't do anything else you don't
need to understand anything else and
once you've simplified them to that
point they can do a much better job so
one of the things that people complain
about in today's networks it takes a
very long time to recover from failures
that if a link goes down it can take
hundreds of milliseconds to recover from
that failure
once the core is not doing anything else
there are recent research result from
from several groups that argue that you
can have the core which respond to
failures on packet delivery times
nanoseconds not hundreds of milliseconds
this is actually what you are doing is
you are changing the modularity again
and pushing connectivity into the data
plane that is you actually put something
in the forwarding a6 it's actually a
very simple thing that if a packet comes
into the wrong direction I remove a
destination from my forwarding table
that's it that's all I need and I can
build a sort of a forwarding fabric that
will never end up not delivering a
packet meaning that when you fail links
it will find a path if it the network is
physically connected it will find a path
at packet delivery times so we can do a
much better job by changing the
modularity once again you also could
imagine once you have this edge course
split why not push the edge all the way
to the host you know it will require
some trusted hardware and software on
the host you know sort of all on the the
host network interface card but we've
got the technology for that so this
isn't trivial this will require you know
a lot of interesting distributed systems
and security issues but one could
imagine actually building networks where
they never saw anything but labels all
the labeling was done off in the Haute
end host themselves ok so let's talk
about misconception number three the
network is comprised entirely of
Hardware switches so on this one we just
got blindsided we just I mean duh we of
course switches our Hardware switches
well you know what what well turns out
that software switches are quite common
every hypervisor has a software switch
right you have a VM here VM here they
want to talk to each other they are
connected by a software switch a V
switch that lives in the hypervisor so
you might say oh yeah ok fine that's a
special case it's not a special case
there are more software ports than
Hardware ports right now if you consider
these switches having software ports to
all of its VMs in 2012 the number of
software ports crossed the number of
hardware ports I'm sure I'm violating
some copyright agreement by showing the
slide but I stole this from somewhere
now
so I can forgive us for not knowing
about this in 2007 if you extrapolate
these curves then hardware clearly
dominated but not now not now software
ports dominate so this idea that the
network is made out of hardware switches
just not true it's not true and not only
that but software switches are getting
much faster now I just need to clarify
when I say software forwarding obviously
all forwarding is done eventually in
hardware so if you're using an x86 a
general-purpose processor that doesn't
know you're doing software forwarding I
call that software forwarding if you're
using a special-purpose ASIC that was
designed with networking protocols in
mind that's hardware forwarding so
that's the the language I'm using and so
a data point that if you use sort of
recent Intel technology you take a
single core it can do 23 and a half
million packets per second of IP view
for forwarding we did this with mid
sized packets that's 16 and a half
gigabits per second for single core if
you extrapolate of what that would be
for average sized packets that's a
single core doing 200 gigs now clearly a
single core camp do 200 gigs it doesn't
have anywhere close to that i/o but the
point is copy
patiently the amount of work you need to
do to do software forwarding is not very
hard at all
so the claim number two I promised you
two controversial claims the claim
number two is the edge can use software
that is when you have this edge core
network all of the edge switches our
software switches of course switches are
still hardware but the edge switches are
software so you can clearly do this in
virtualized data centers because that's
what's happening already they use the V
switch and the hypervisor if you look at
a large ISP verizon and AT&T Deutsche
Telekom and you look at the total amount
of bandwidth that they send inter domain
that crosses their borders and you ask
how much would I have to spend to buy
enough cores to do that forwarding one
hundred and fifty thousand dollars
that's not even the price of mid-range
router so the amount of forwarding you
need to do software forwarding is
trivial and so when you look at other
examples of enterprise networks and so
forth I don't see any setting where it
would be infeasible to do software
forwarding at the edge it may not be as
cheap as you can do it today in most
cases it certainly won't be as cheap as
you can do it today but you certainly
can do it so let me talk a little bit
about software versus hardware because
I'm not claiming the software forwarding
is as fast or cost-effective as Hardware
forwarding you know people who know
better than I tell me there's two orders
of magnitude difference and it's
probably growing I'm fine with that my
point is that the edge forwarding
requirements can be met with software
and that we would be better off with the
increased flexibility of software at the
edge we don't need to use it in the core
because we don't need any flexibility in
the core of the cords just doing label
based forwarding hardware is great for
that but at the edge we should use
software so we're not limited by what
current Asics can do
so the law I I hope you will forgive me
I'm not going to tell you about a
long-term opportunity this present this
is one of my sort of academic obsessions
so if you don't like to think about
internet architecture you can turn your
brain off for 30 seconds and I'll come
back to it but what this could do if you
put the software at the edge is you
could allow architectural evolution in
diversity what I mean by that is you
build let's say 18 T or Deutsche Telekom
they build their domain with software at
the edge hardware internally only the
software at the edge knows that you're
running an intra main protocol meaning
those you're running IP everything else
internally is protocol agnostic think of
it as you know layer 2 Ethernet or
protocol agnostic they don't care
whether you're writing v4 v6 so now if
you want to change architectures like
going from ipv4 to ipv6 that's just
changing your Sdn control program says
rather than looking at this bits in your
packet header and doing that match look
at these bits in your packet header and
do that match that's it that's the ipv4
to ipv6 transition right there it's that
simple and then if you want to do
something radical you may have heard
about these information-centric
networking that say you know network
shouldn't be designed around the socket
interface about sending packets it
should be this pub/sub interface about
getting content and that's a radical
change we need to change the entire
network that's just changing your Sdn
control program quite seriously that's
all it takes now you do need to make
some modifications on the end host but
in terms of the network infrastructure
it is an update to your Sdn control
program now you might be saying butBut
how can you change the architecture the
thing we've all been taught in
networking class is that the internet
works because we have this narrow waist
that everybody agrees upon and then of
course everybody agrees that you you
need a narrow waist and that quite
simply is we don't need a
narrow waist I can explain why the
narrow waist comes because we've
conflated Ethernet with domains but
that's a longer lecture but domains can
run many architectures in parallel and
to support these architectures in
parallel and do it on the host
it's conceptually radical but the
technical changes you need to make are
embarrassingly simple so this is easily
within our technical range it's just a
question of convincing people it's
worthwhile to do
okay so end of rant that so let's go on
to misconception number four and
something that somebody other than me
cares about and here there's the network
dating data plane is fairly simple and
Here I am stealing content from Silvia
rotten Asami a colleague of mine at
Berkeley and there's a saying about
artists that good artists borrow and
great artists steal so in this regard in
this regard only I claim greatness so
the myth of the Internet's data plane is
that the Internet only provides best
effort delivery and that that's enough
to satisfy users the reality is that
these things called middleboxes or
network appliances are used to augment
the data plane and they do all sorts of
stuff ok so you have firewalls you have
LAN optimizers you have proxies you have
gateways you have VPNs you have load
balancers and you have intrusion
detection and that's only a partial list
so you have lots of things on the data
plane that are doing things it's not
simple the other thing that's very
shocking is that sylvia's group found
that when you go do measurements and you
look at small networks medium networks
large networks and very large networks
and you count the number of middle boxes
and you compare it to the number of
routers and the number of switches and
they're comparable middle boxes you
shouldn't think of your network at all
it's all switches and routers and there
are a few middle boxes over here that I
can treat the special case no there are
as many middle boxes as there are
routers so there are 4 important facts
to remember one is most packets are
touched by several middle boxes ah sorry
thank you for asking that a middle box
is so I have this beautiful pristine
textbook network switches and routers
packet gets routed between switches and
the routers and they go the only time
anybody understands a packet is when
it's sent from this house and when it's
received at that house that's the
Internet and then I'm gonna big bad
middleboxes gonna be stuck in the middle
of the day to plant a packet comes in
and this box and we call it a middle box
it's stuck in the middle will then look
at the packet and make some decision
about that packet like I don't like the
content of this back and I'm going to
drop it or I'm going to look at this
packet and see if somebody's attacking
me or I'm going to be a firewall and I'm
going to control connections and that's
why it is data planing that it is stuck
right in the middle it has no official
role in the flow going on but it's
making decisions about package so thank
you for asking that so that's what a
middle box is so now let me get back to
those four facts most packets go through
several of them they're typically
deployed at the edge of the network they
typically not always but they typically
use x86 packet processing and the things
they do the packet are much more
complicated than what you would do if
you were just simply forwarding the
packet okay so if you accept these four
facts there's one absolutely inescapable
conclusion which is that Sdn should
implement middle box functionality at
the edge in software replacing all these
separate boxes that we have currently do
it you know we put in these separate
boxes being middle boxes but we ought to
be doing it at the edge in software
right because it's already being done at
the edge in software just not by Sdn so
Sdn just should bring it under its
domain and when you do that you have now
cemented the case for edge software
forwarding because software forwarding
was necessary for middle boxes it's
already being used for middle boxes
doing I mean software processing doing
the extra forwarding is a tiny
additional if you have enough cores to
do your middle box functionality you
essentially have enough cores to do your
software forwarding on top of it yeah
you mean by the edge and is there only
one edge it ends means anytime a packet
from a host and end host enters the
network that first top is an edge
boundaries between domains nice piece
are not edges ah I should say there are
two ended right there's when it leaves a
host or when
entering from another trust trust domain
and so that would be two domains who are
connected that don't trust each other
then you have to consider that an edge
because any label that would have been
inserted by that domain I will I don't
either trust or don't know the meaning
of it and it traverses many edges
getting from one place to another
yes so if we buy this that we're going
to do software forwarding at the edge
this represents a radical shift from
hardware to software the hardware
network goes back to being dumb pipes
but they were in the beginning when we
actually didn't have any metal boxes and
actually the network just forwarded
packets and everything interesting
happens in software at the edge under
the control of Sdn this is the truly
disruptive nature of Sdn there was a yes
our current understanding of middle
boxes work do we know if they're
processing every packet that flows
through them are only processing a
sample of the packets flowing through
them it really depends on the middle box
because if it's the case that they're
only processing a sample of them then by
using software it forward every packet
and necessarily process every packet
wouldn't you be introducing a lot more
network latency you wouldn't be
introducing more network latency oh yes
you would have been ignored by the
middle boxes packing meanie ah so if
what you're saying is that I'm going to
do something very slow on some packets
but what you would say is I need to have
enough core capacity so that I can for
that line right yeah and if I can't do
it with one core I take two cores and if
I can do with two I take seven and so if
I'm forwarding it line right then you
don't increase the latency yeah what
what what's the commercial impact of
this observation this seems to me to be
very disruptive to current network
hardware not attack
let's get to that idea okay because III
think that that's a subject for a
prolonged discussion so well I want to
step back because we've now gotten to
this place where we would focus on
software for anything you might say you
know you said you were coming here to
talk about Sdn and now you're talking
about software forwarding how do we get
from here to there so let me
recapitulate Sdn established this nice
control plane modularity switches
network operating system control
programs they all have their own jobs
and that virtualization came in and
decoupled the control program from the
physical network so what this did is the
control program just expressed its goals
on a virtual topology that gave the Sdn
platform full control over how it
implemented those desires and then we
said now that the Sdn platform has full
freedom it's going to say let me put the
functionality at the edge and just do
forwarding in the core you removed all
but all functionality but connectivity
from the core and then the last step we
said in G by the way at the edge we can
use software there we can forward fast
enough to do software there and that
last step pulls all the functionality
out of any ASIC there is no longer any
complicated functionality in the Asics
the Asics are just doing label
forwarding and all the complicated
functionality is now at the edge in
software so that's why Sdn played such a
role because it is able to control where
the functionality is implemented and
manage the network in that way that you
can put it in the one place where you
can replace hardware forwarding with
software 40 now you might say why do I
care so much about software I mean was i
beaten up by an ASIC when I was a child
and and you know and the point is
software for ting is a stable forwarding
platform that does not limit
functionality you know so I want to
match over the first 500 bytes I can do
that if I want to match over the first
30 bytes I can do that it doesn't matter
I'm not told of well this ASIC only
supports matches up to X bytes and if
you want to do more than that we just
can't do it now obviously if I want to
match over more bytes that go slower but
we're used to that in software that if
you ask something to do more
it goes slower but it doesn't fall off a
cliff and it's a platform to get faster
over time new functionalities deployed
merely through software upgrades and
hardware upgrades are largely
transparent I just I put new hardware
and it goes faster yeah daddy's talking
I think it's faster first time so we can
be only appropriate person to say I'm
sorry what I'd never slips off me that
you got faster over time without metal
hardware underneath and we know Moore's
laws reach the end so that's going to
happen so I forget slower over time
unbeliev in many core powers constrain
what I would say that first of all if
you look at the recent forwarding rates
x86 forwarding rates have increased
dramatically over the last couple of
years so whatever they're doing they're
figuring out just like virtualization
has gotten better I don't care about
Moore's law but people are figuring out
what instructions we need to do
forwarding faster and that's clearly you
don't see any curve that looks like
that's flattened off maybe it will in a
few years but we also can spread you
know forwarding packets is highly
parallelizable using multi-core for that
is very easy because we just we
typically are not joining the forwarding
one packet tuna
lycée actually I thought you man it was
going to reduce latency but using
multiple cores is not going to slay oh
I'm sorry I understand that you care a
lot about latency by that is at the
cording rate of a single packet that the
latency that you know if I can go at 200
gigs computationally then whether when
the capacity the total you know that
latency in the switch is not the main
thing that I'm worried about in terms of
latency so I care about increasing
aggregate bandwidth I care about can I
have a thousand port thousand by ten
ports which that's what I care about the
actual latency on an individual line is
low enough that I don't think that's
that's the issue forwarding even
software
you gave a number that was throughput
but you didn't get actual latency number
no I don't have that number also I'm
curious a for example this is assuming
that you're doing a packet closer to go
across the US and take hundreds of
milliseconds so you don't mind wasting a
few tens of my per seconds on each and
doing the software business yeah so I I
don't have that number I don't have that
number so the nice thing about this
platform provides both stability and
innovation there's a much more stable
customer experience then certainly if
you try and do a network upgrade and
there's more innovation and competition
both in the hardware and the software
platforms
and this is much like the x86
computational platform over the past
decades so this is why I say given the
title of my talk that Sdn and networking
in general is at the crossroad that the
question is will networking in Sdn be
defined by the limitations of Asics that
is there are certain things you can and
can't do or will it embrace the
generality of software for DES so I'm
not claiming the move to software will
be trivial or fast it requires new
thinking you know how exactly do you
want to structure your software what are
the kinds of matches you can do in
software that weren't practical and
hardware new products like how do I get
a high port density software switch
those aren't really available today and
you need new players people who roll in
the marketplaces to fill those niches
right now they're not there but this
move is inevitable and it's already
underway that is if you look at what's
going on in middleboxes you're already
paying that latency if that's your
concern all we're saying now is you want
to take advantage of the fact that this
is already going on to generalize your
functionality it's certainly going on in
a virtualized data centers and this
transition and this is getting to the
point that was raised before will change
the nature of the networking industry
it's faster innovation more competition
and better customer experience and with
that thank you
yeah distributed denial-of-service
attacks
rely on this boy right in the future so
what I would say is that any mechanism
you would want to deploy that you could
deploy more easily by doing it in
software at the edge then you could do
now by saying okay little box I put it
in a tub point so that I can do whatever
countermeasures so it doesn't magically
solve it but it gives you a much easier
deployment path for those kinds of
solution I mean you're talking about
interim solution this doesn't inter
debate yes yeah I've been reading that a
lot of people are trying to apply a
scheme to layer four problems like load
balancing you know some hard ones that
hardware has done pretty well at like
SSL termination that's kind of expensive
um you know and I know I do think these
changes are going to occur but what is
your take in much closer to this on all
that so no I think there are some things
that are going to be slower faster than
others but I think eventually it's all
going to be eaten by generalize you know
I think that there is a lot more to be
learned about how you can accelerate
various tasks I mean the one thing that
Intel is really good at is if you give
it workloads it will go into
exhaustively look at gee what
instruction would speed this up we're at
the very early stages of looking at the
entire x86 could do to make these things
faster really quick question on that is
are people in the industry right now
using commodity hardware like just
standard rackmount pcs to implement
these network operating systems the
other problem is is that that's just uh
that's not on the data plate the
question is where are they implementing
the data and some middle boxes are
essentially stock servers that just have
a few cards stuck all
I once was on an airplane sitting next
to somebody obviously a Salesman because
the only people who talked to me on
their planes I put on this sort of very
antisocial demeanor you can tell
somebody start talking to me I know it's
a salesman and this person you know I
found out work for a company that sold
security middleboxes
and so I said you know what use
special-purpose process you know to you
and any SEC yeah you know and then sort
of after about a half-hour he said well
you know actually our old bonds use the
special purpose processor our new bonds
you six but we can't admit that to any
of our customers because our whole
marketing campaign was based on special
purpose hardware but but but but that
they too had sort of decided that the
flexibility was such that writing the
technology what are your thoughts about
the color and space constraints when the
edge is not a virtual data center but
the edge is a central office as a Metro
edge or a point of presence and so on
red power and space the compass have
become scarce resources that made
software at your as your edge well how
do you think if you get realized or when
will it get realized because those
constraints making it difficult for
people to deploy a software as an agent
it's not a host but surely a network
coming in as an edge as it so I think
that's going to be one of those cases
where on the one power consumption and
on the other hand we have better
flexibility and different markets will
make the transition at very different
times that is that when people recognize
that once I move to an x86 platform I
actually have to upgrade my equipment
much less often
certainly upgrade my software much less
often that it's a better you know sort
of total cost of ownership that's going
to differ based on different scenarios
and and I don't claim to have any
special insight
about that so you talk about hardware a6
and software x86 processors but there's
a continuum in there there are these
network processors do you see any role
for these sorts of things or you think
it will just be you know x86 everywhere
um I don't I don't want to make a
definitive statement on that I think
that the people I talk to about
middleboxes
seem to think that network processors
are getting a smaller share of the
market than they used to but you know I
I don't wanna make a definitive
statement but it seems like they've had
a very hard time finding the sweet spot
that's where we program it the
flexibility is much better than but the
speed is much better than x86 is I think
that gap this is is narrowing the
implementation of these mostly linux on
x86 with a real-time minimal or is it
some other they mean how you afford
it yeah right so so I mean the you know
it tell has this DP DK forwarding thing
that is typically what we took our
measurements on they just want it so you
know x86 the real regular standard I
think it's a regular stable so with if
no one's become much more programmable
essentially inflexible what kind of
effect does that have on participants
like what do persistent mins become in
that world is Amazon just start hiring
way more C programmers it's like right I
mean I think there would be sort of two
separate they're the sort of edge to
edge network delivery where the network
has a very simple task and there will be
network administrators to sort of make
sure that happens and then there will be
people who will be sort of more about
the sort of the the S
the ends of auxiliary functionality that
will be hopefully programs yeah and I
guess like that I'm like where's miss do
it do you uh and vision these things
being changed like to maybe watch your
writing code sort of on live networks or
is it or would it still be more of a
model more like you have some vendor
like Cisco's everything just writing new
boxes at a more rapid pace because
they're easier to deploy so um I imagine
there will be coming that write software
that they will go directly to users and
say this will solve your problem so
aside from the table our high speeds or
the large data centers I don't imagine
many end customers will be writing their
own control programs but there will be
companies that do and how I'm living in
happens to be one of those bought the
house that I haven't be living so the
control program is that is there a
single control program is this a large
distributed program which shares
information with other instances of the
same program what what is it so it's
very complicated right so so that
actually when you're writing a control
program is a distributed system system
running over a cluster not widely
distributed over the entire network so
it's not really just a single box you
know you need to shard the problem and
spread it over several servers but you
get to control that rather than being
the victim of the topology of the
network going by some core edge model
what I mean that there will be minimal
ventilation opportunity in the core area
because maybe again we use of MPLS
we may be the Guru mineral opportunity
to do innovation yeah good zone so
actually know um that that something
like having networks that respond to
link failures immediately that's
something we don't do now they're
terrible about that and I think that's
certainly within technological reach so
I think that it would be not in terms of
broad-based functionality but it would
in terms of you know
metrics of how fast you recover from
failures and you know how fast can you
support multicast joins and things like
that okay so you use MPLS you know it's
already ours today
yeah but but but but it doesn't recover
very well from calories so you know you
need to build in that that stuff yeah so
a really interesting talk really
provocative because I never box trucks
in here question like it is Ranger me
because everything so differently but a
lot of questions I mean first but I
one thing about my idea of Sdn is kind
of different the idea that testing is
simply making switches programmable and
enabling api's into the protocols and I
remember somebody I don't remember who
it was gave us really interesting talk
about like the end of protocols in the
future network but that was kind of good
and I wonder and so this leads me to
question your idea of a hypervisor
running on top of the operating system
because usually a hypervisor just
creates sort of recreates a hardware
interface or sort of duplicates it and
and you know virtualizes it and so the
question I question for you is why do
you think that the role programs will
want to use the same interface talking
to your hypervisor as they would use
talking to hardware because it would
seem to make a lot more sense to me to
have an API that doesn't necessarily
mean the hardware interface at all ah so
you're absolutely right except right now
if I'm running a network and I want to
move it to the cloud I think in terms of
switches and configurations right now if
the cloud said we've got this great
interface you know you have to learn
into language and it's got this other
policy thing but you can do whatever you
want I'd say no thanks if you say you
can take the configuration you're using
in your network and move it to the cloud
I'll do it but you're absolutely right I
would hope ten years from now if we're
still using that interface I would be
very disappointed but right now it's
this is what people understand how to
think about networks and um you know the
early days of Nasir I will you know when
we went out and talked to people we
would say you can do all this great
stuff and their answers
in terms of Ackles and these low-level
mechanisms they could not articulate a
policy it was and so giving them an
interface that they understand is the
first step but I absolutely grew that
was what I was trying to say about more
general abstractions I would hope that
the virtualization layer supported much
more general abstractions in the future
that didn't force people into thinking
about it the way networks work right now
just virtualize the hardware they
actually provide convenient higher level
abstractions like you know files rather
than a virtual disk or processes rather
than you know virtual addresses but and
sometimes are virtualized but often you
get these are higher level abstractions
which are much more convenient we're
going complete agreement we're going to
play truth
what abacus dean and the new smaller
network start-ups have to say about this
Oh Andy Bekele Stevie oh yeah so what is
the risk to think about this
I would not want for Wednesday's next
era you know I think the right way to
think about this is this is disruptive
it will create new opportunities and it
will render some old paths less relevant
I mean building sort of very fast
fabrics is a really important thing and
doing that well is incredibly important
so I don't want to diminish that at all
so there's going to be a role for
Hardware here and just it's sort of the
allocation of functionality maybe a
little bit different or you know I would
be advocating deformed it's not like
home bass was in the market go away so
colleagues affect the core routers are
going to be specialized Hardware they're
going to be just another instance of a
sort of standard server that you buy
off-the-shelf
although I assume core hardware
we have 40 boxes that's because of the
multiplicity of network for that I was
just so curious if I understood you
correctly can you realize a CCN like
model or architecture using the
controller what are the modification
because the controller can tell the edge
software what to do so that the
controller can say you know when when
you look at the packet look at the using
some kind of name based networking
architecture look at the name of the
content go check your cache if it's
there the action you take is to respond
with the object if not you forward it
the way in the end would you know it's
just saying that that I you know that
something that the software can do let
me take one more so in the core do you
still feel that Sdn and a controller
should manage those even if they have
like diminish functionality or it's
simpler because a good chunk of Sdn is
about manageability and they're not
going to manage themselves
Lissa's yeah yeah no so I would imagine
the core still managed by his DS
absolutely absolutely
okay so I said what would holla to
confuse we middle boxes coming bringing
all the functionality at the edge so the
flow table these brings this very
natural decoupling between the fast data
plane and then the longer timescale
control plane but the moment you bring
the little box is there where you have
per packet processing this seems to be a
bit mixed up again and so do you do you
think of any abstractions on the middle
box that could go down to per packet
processing that could be similarly
abstracted to an SDN controller I'm not
sure so he do I think they're
abstractions that are middle boxes could
export to a control
so the controller could understand what
they were trying to do so what I'm
saying is Sdn we have the flow table and
these gives these decoupling of a very
fast data plane in a very much slower
Pinero plane the moment you bring middle
boxes and per packet processing into
this picture right which seats in the
data plane it's not clear to me how the
separation of control plane and other
thing happens right but I thought that
the part of your question I would object
to is we didn't bring little boxes into
this picture they are part of getting
here and we're just we're just dealing
it so that they would be part of what we
manage but but wasn't my idea to bring
them there that ok so thank you very
much
you